let me bring you some breaking news now
Saudi Arabia and the us see the warning
sides in Sudan have agreed to a
Nationwide ceasefire but only for 24
hours starting on Saturdays the latest
in several attempts to stop weeks of
fighting between the Army and the para
military rapid support forces we're
going to go live to Heber Morgan she's
in onderman across the Nile River from
Khartoum let's talk about the ceasefire
first of all 24 hours does not seem like
a very long time what more do we know
well what we do know is that this
24-hour period that was uh proposed by
the mediators Saudi Arabia and the
United States for the two sides the
touring sites the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces is a
form of confidence building that's the
statement that was what was stated in
the press release by the Saudi foreign
Ministry now it's supposed to be similar
to the previous ceasefire where there
should be no artillery strikes there
should be no airstrikes launched by the
Sudanese Army there should be no
fighting between the two sides and no
military gains made by the two sides if
the two sides are able to implement that
then that according to the statement
from the ministry would pave the way for
further talks between the two sides and
it would also allow for humanitarian
assistance much needed humanitarian
assistance to reach these uh those who
are trapped in areas of conflict around
the country now the statement also makes
it very very clear that should that be
violated like the previously as far as I
violated then the talks that are ongoing
in Jeddah would come to an end because
has there's been so many frustration as
per the statement that both mediators
are frustrated by the repeated
violations by both sides and that
they're not ready to continue watching
more violations as they try to bring an
end to this conflict between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army
here but just as you've been talking to
us we've been looking at some of the the
pictures from Wednesday about the
fighting that have been happening in
cartoon and I think I can see some smoke
Rising on the horizon behind you bring
this up to date with the latest on the
fighting
when it's not stopped a single day since
it started in mid-april even during the
ceasefires that would agreed upon by
both sides for a period of seven days
and then extend it for another five days
now there were reports of artillery
being used around your mooc in the
southern part of the capital Khartoum
that's around a weapons manufacturing
company that belongs to the Sudanese
Army and which on late Tuesday the rsf
on late Wednesday sorry the rsf was able
to take control of there's also been
Antonov planes flying overhead from the
city of onderman heading towards the
southern part of the capital Khartoum
and we were able to hear Heavy Artillery
being fired here in umdurman in various
directions we know from residents in the
southern part of umbderman city that
there's been airstrikes Heavy Artillery
against deposit rsf positions people in
the north also in the Northern parts of
the capital also repeatedly reported a
hearing heavy artillery and gunfight
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army so fighting is very much
ongoing residents have very little faith
that this ceasefire would actually stop
the fighting even briefly even if it's a
period of just 24 hours Heather thank
you very much indeed Heber Morgan
talking to us from onderman